l'automobile va mal et ce n'est pas un
scoop oui tout à fait un tome il est
très présente dans le département tout
d'abord peugeot à poissy où la
production de la 208 et fortement freiné
suite à une réduction d'effectifs de 500
intérimaires la la 208 sera fabriquée à
35 unités par heure contre 52
actuellement et puis chez renault la
production de la zoé de la clio 4 à
flins pen a commencé suite aux nombreux
débrayages des salariés pour alerter sur
les conditions de travail et de salaires
pourquoi les la situation le conseil
général des yvelines rencontrera lundi
prochain les syndicats de l'industrie
pour mettre en place un plan de soutien
comme il l'avait déjà fait en 2009 et
110 cars de toute l'industrie automobile
pas uniquement un constructeur mais
toute l'industrie automobile merci ali
ce procès reines prochaines pages éco
pardon ce sera la semaine prochaine même
heure et puisque vous parlez de la
situation dans l'automobile revenons sur
la colère qui gronde du côté de flins
pas de grève mais une mobilisation des
syndicats qui dénonçaient cet après midi
les conditions de travail dans une usine
appartenant à renault les explications
d'anthony rech
avec le lancement de la nouvelle renault
clio iv et de la zoé la voiture
électrique de la marque le rendement de
l'usiné de flins augmente mais les
salariés sont confrontés à un manque
d'effectifs selon les syndicats présents
aux portes du centre ce jeudi midi on
est en colère parce que il faut si on
veut fabriquer correctement des voitures
il faut du personnel et entre les gars
qui morfle sur les chaînes etc d'un côté
et ceux qui morfle du chômage à côté
c'est inadmissible et où ça s'est
exprimée vraiment par des arrêts de
travail ce matin pour contraindre la
direction à prendre l'effectif suffisant
encore ce matin il ya eu une heure et
demi d'arrêt de travail des caristes
pour réclamer du personnel
supplémentaire parce que ils n'arrivent
pas à décharger les camions ils
n'arrivent pas à mettre les pièces là où
il faut et c'est les salariés de renault
flins se rendront mardi 9 octobre pour
manifester au mondial de l'automobile
avant de se joindre à un cortège
nationale à l'appel des syndicats
européens
et si vous avez manqué notre spécial
salon de l'automobile lundi dernier
séance de rattrapage ce week-end sur tv
fils depuis la porte de versailles à
paris retour sur les nouveautés du salon
qui se déroule vous l'avez bien compris
sur fond de crise pour le secteur vous
découvrirez les derniers modèles
électriques mais aussi le travail mené
par des petits constructeurs du
département édition spéciale ad samedi à
10 heures les autres horaires se sont
affichés jusqu'au dimanche à minuit vous
pourrez suivre cette édition spéciale
nous poursuivons à présent cette édition
du 4 octobre en direct jusqu'à 19 heures
avec une opération mené par yveline
information jeunesse à versailles le
deuxième forum rentrer infos jeunes